M it's
God it's
God you became a Muslim before that what
what convinced you it just made more
sense all around I was always confused
about the
Trinity
um about everything like how how it did
not make sense so you're saying the
Trinity didn't make sense to you but the
concept of God and Islam made sense yeah
and and so what is it about the concept
of Allah in Islam that you're like you
know what that that that sets with me
what what what is it if something pops
in your head it's more like like for
example I don't know you see a p like
look look at these Billboards up here
you know what I'm saying you're you're
not going to think that just appeared
out of nowh like someone created that
you know right but but the world the
world the way it's designed is Artistic
how does that what I'm what I'm asking
is how does that get you away from
Christianity I guess cuz Christians
believe the same thing above everyone
you know anywhere you go there's one
person above everyone okay I just wasn't
feeling it in Christianity like I do
with do do you believe that I go I went
to church twice a week I did not feel it
the same so okay so what would you say
to like let's say for like have you
heard of Mormonism people like they go
around they got their little you know
badges on they go door too they're
Mormons they say that when they pray and
in their religion they feel you know
that it's true and they they feel you
know I didn't feel that I felt it for
so do would you say that they're valid
to say that their religion is true since
they like have a feeling towards it of
course they're valid of course it can't
so you you guys can't both be right no
but that's how I feel all religion is
about peace you know we're not we're not
going to tell you no come to Islam right
now oh you man you'll be surprised bro
do you know how many people I get I get
inbox some people you know that's what
that's that's most that's the Quran no
but the reality is that peace like you
know what I'm saying it's not everyone
has their own Journey everyone has their
own Journey but this so this is what I'm
going to say to you guys cuz like I I
hear what you're saying right you're
saying Islam let me say I'm about to
tell you you said that you know Islam
resonated with you more and you're
saying Islam is a religion of peace
right and and it's like it's inclusive
what I'm saying is is that one if we're
talking about truth our feelings don't
determine what like is the is reality is
the truth cuz somebody can have a
feeling towards something that is
actually not real not it's not true the
whole point in Christianity you feel the
Holy Spirit I guess depending on your
denomination yeah no absolutely not is
um what is it
called it PE Protestant sorry Protestant
yes Protestant probably Pentecostal
another denomination Pentecostal yes p p
see that was all based on emotions for
me yeah I agree I agree it's a it has a
high emotionalism but what I'm saying is
that you can still get grounded in what
truth is outside of that right you can
the truth is in what what do God say in
the scripture you know I I read the
scripture all my life and I was
finding things that weren't consistent
like that give me I want to give good an
example maybe I can help with that when
Jesus was found in his tomb okay why was
there three different stories there's
not there is depending on your version
of the Bible you're reading there's
three different well so let me let me
clear this up okay cuz that's actually a
good question people have this a lot so
one so you have Matthew Mar Luke and
John they're giving their eyewitness
testimony of what happened right why are
their eyewitness testimony because they
it's almost like this let's say you like
we're here right let's say we just saw a
car accident okay a blue car crashed
into this building right now I say um a
car crashed into the building he says a
blue Toyota crashed into the building
and you say man something crashed into
the building were we all did we
contradict each
other no oh but it was way I would have
to go back and read it it was way more
varation no it's not this what I can
tell you look as I Witnesses we can give
different details on what we focus on of
the same event it doesn't mean that
we're contradicting each other similarly
when they're giving the account of the
Resurrection you know like Mark for
example would just mention he said Mary
went to the tomb and Found Jesus he
didn't mention the other women right but
or John would mention Mary Magdalene and
somebody else and then Luke would say
marry Magdalene and name another woman
right now it they don't contradict each
other they're just adding more details
okay that they choose to focus on but
they don't contradict does that make
sense just like eyewitnesses can have
different details of an account that
don't contradict it's the same with the
gospel accounts okay yeah so like the
that's what I'm saying like these are
it's a good question people have how do
we know these people
wrote parts of the Bible good question
yeah so we have what is called church
history right we have oral tradition so
we have the apostles who were with Jesus
right who wrote the the right wrote it
down and then they have people that
after them that continued to pass down
the tradition so we have 2,000 years
worth of church history that backs up
that Mark wrote Mark Luke wrote Luke
John Ro John you know Matthew wrot
Matthew my thing is the Quran it's one
book it's consistent on every page no
it's what what if I show you that it's
not so like for example I I so like this
is interesting what part is not yeah
that's what I'm about to share so you
have the Quran right that says it's one
witness right it's supposed to be from
God so unlike the B like the Bible has
four the gospel is four Matthew Mark
Luke and John four Witnesses the Quran
is just Muhammad right one man should be
one consist story however you have one
instance right you guys know about the
birth of Jesus when the Angels come to
her and right okay so in chapter three
it says that Angels Came to to Mary and
told her hey you're about to give give
birth to a boy named Jesus right to the
Messiah it says Angels came through you
believe that too right I know know is
the Messiah right we just don't believe
he's the son of God which not God that's
see if you can't say that he's the
Messiah and disregard that but let me
finish this point okay so here's the
point I forgot what his name but someone
else consider the Son of God we'll we'll
break that down we'll break that down I
promise like just I promise you I can
clear up all this stuff okay so in
Chapter 3 of the Quran it said Angels
Came to Mary and told her about the baby
now when you go to chapter 19 sah Mariam
right the chapter of Mary it actually
says that one Spirit the Spirit came to
Mary and told her about her having a
baby now if we're going to have problems
with like different details then you
have to say oh well the Quran has a
problem because one part it says Angels
Came and the other part it says the
Spirit came you know so which one was it
you know what I'm saying so if you're
saying about consistencies that would be
something if if we're going to be
consistent they cooking right now they
cooking how do we know what the
encounters like the difference between
an angel and spirit how do we know the
difference between an angel and spirit
well so the uh the Quran Says angels and
it's in the plural right the word is
mala or something like that spirit in
Arabic is R okay so in chapter 19 it
says The Rook came to Mary in a form of
a perfect man and told her you're going
to have a son
and the other one it says Angels Gabriel
right no no see in the Quran it doesn't
say that Gabriel is the spirit that's
what people believe but the Quran never
says that oh Gabriel is the spirit and
that's that's a misconception a lot of
people have yeah you know but about
about the Messiah thing Jesus being the
Messiah he is the Son of God that's what
I'm saying like you can't say that Jesus
is the Messiah but also say he's not the
Son of God as well cuz that's literally
intrinsic to his identity that's almost
like saying you know you call someone a
king
right but you say he's not a ruler it's
like similar to that like give me the
definition of Messiah Give me the
definition all right so the definition
is Anointed one so if you're looking at
the word messiah in general just the
word the definition is Anointed one now
you need to see what is he anointed for
who is he what is he and so you go to
the Bible and it tells you who the
Messiah is it tells you that he's going
to be born of a virgin and it says that
he's born of a virgin and his name Shall
be Called Emmanuel which means literally
in HEB
god with us so it literally tells us
about the Messiah that God is going to
come in the flesh to be born through a
woman maybe means to God's word maybe
yeah maybe it means God's word come on
God's word what with us God no God With
Us us right now but is he is he present
with you we say peace be with you God be
with
you it's you said that you said that you
say peace be with you right the
interesting thing who do you say is the
source of peace God God right well Jesus
him he said I give you peace he said my
peace I give to you not as the world
gives but my peace I leave with you does
that sound like somebody who doesn't
believe he's God he's saying he's the
source of peace see I agree with you
that Jesus you know it's special Donal
but why Donald Trump's trying to find
peace as well Donald Trump he said
Donald Trump is trying to find peace
too no but no he's not trying to find
see Jesus wasn't trying to find peace he
said that he's the source of
he's different Messiah for us means the
one that is going to come after the day
of judgment it's the same as you you go
the Antichrist you go Jesus is going to
come Messiah thei savior okay so so so
let's think of this okay if if you were
to let's take the let's take this
meaning of Messiah he's the one who's
going to come at the end times and kill
the Antichrist right so when he first
came how was anybody supposed to believe
that he was the Messiah how would he
prove that how how would we know
that he's the Messiah before any of the
end time stuff happened cuz that a that
that hasn't happened yet so how would
you know that he's the
Messiah if we're if we're to think about
it because the Quran said so well that's
not enough because the Quran comes 600
years after so what how do you know he
the Quran is more accurate on historical
I'm trying to educate myself that's a
good question brother the Quran is more
accurate on historical events so let's
let's talk about this okay if um if
we're going to talk about how how we
know about Jesus the history of his life
you don't get it from the Quran okay
like for example where do you get it
from the Bible yes why the Bible because
that's the eyewitness testimony the
people who walked with Jesus who lived
with them witness but who
is the Quran I told you guys already the
Quran they say is God's word like so so
how is God not the eye witness so this
this is what it is cuz that's just a
claim right just like she's saying okay
but how would you prove but the ey
witness the Bible
yeah you're right let let me let me land
this guys let me land this cuz we're
talking about establishing history right
so this is what it is if we're having
eyewitness testimony people who walked
with Jesus they would know about him
right they lived with him they heard him
speak they heard his teachings so they
would write them down and so then they
would also pass on the tradition to
their students and to their students and
to their students 2,000 years of history
of that so what we have is but it's not
though because in the Quran it comes 600
years after Jesus and is not connected
to him at all the difference with the
Quran is that Muhammad he was
illiterate and it's like how would he be
able to plan all of this out by himself
because he wasn't by himself he actually
had a person named wara who was a
Christian that he was learning under so
wara was a Christian according to the
Hadith he was way long it's in
sahkari sahkar it's AI it's where you
get the history of Muhammad okay what
level of um what is it called huh what's
the grating of theith it's sah it's
sahkari it's the highest authentic
Hadith book okay I'll have to look into
that yeah yeah it's it's interesting so
it tells us that you know Muhammad was
really close with waraka who happened to
be a Christian who was also writing the
gospel he was making copies of the
Gospel so he would learn from Mora and
also he was surrounded by Jews who would
also recite the Torah in their language
I can't hear you guys oh that's
so yeah speak um can I have my face
covered yeah
cover absolutely yeah we'll blank out
your face no problem we blur the whole
thing yeah but what's it called so what
is is this what you do like yeah we just
have we just have conversation I try to
try to inform people man you know uh
people like you guys man you guys are
cool you guys are chill and you guys are
asking good questions and you just need
to be informed I'm I'm going to be dead
honest with you like I I I'm not a
scholar or nothing
saying I'm going to tell this this that
like and have the facts right there
saying yeah it's that being an a level
math student I'm I'm not no no I got you
but that's what I'm saying you guys are
asking question tell I'll tell you like
what's it called what you need to do is
actually speak to a proper scholar where
are they uh this there's someone on
YouTube he's from London dude find
someone called Ali da I spoke to him he
kicked me he he kicked me out he kicked
you out yeah he kicked me out of stream
I was I was talking to him about where
where the sign at where's the Jesus as a
Muslim sign that's what I was talking to
him about I was talking to him about
Jesus being a Muslim I talked to him and
his sh God logic God logic yeah okay
wait wait so I talked to him YouTube or
TI Tok YouTube both both okay yeah go to
YouTube y it's right there post I had a
I had a whole conversation with him but
see this is this is what I want to leave
you guys with if anything if you're
going to call Jesus the Messiah you have
to know exactly what that means because
if you know it then you have to you
can't you have to leave Islam or not
call him that anymore if you're saying m
this what I'm saying if he's the Messiah
then that means that he's the Divine Son
of God Who Came In the Flesh why why do
I have to leave my religion do you care
about truth Messiah doesn't mean son
where does it say that it means
son hold on let me answer a question let
me ask you one wait wait one second one
let me answer a question let me ask you
something wait let me answer a question
bro I got to answer
her she has a good questioned to say now
all right go ahead look you know have
the S how you were saying like oh Islam
like you was making it seem like we come
and try no you you can't believe in that
this that you're doing that right now
bro doing what like oh no you have to
come to Christianity that's L what you
just said well this is my this is my
mission bro my mission is to give you
the truth right and have you accepted
you know that's is what it is Tru I the
TRU but you no but you didn't but this
is what I'm saying sister as as we're
talking you know un like just to be real
with you as we're talking there's a lot
of things that you didn't know and
that's okay right we all have
misconceptions sometimes what I'm saying
is is that you never really knew
Christianity you know what I'm saying
you never really looked deep into this I
had the holy spirit before no I had the
Holy Spirit no I still left see this
this is the this is the thing now if if
you're saying if you're saying if you're
saying wait let me let me respond to
that if you're saying that you you're
religion if you if you're saying that
you had the the Holy Spirit then the
Holy Spirit would guide you into the
truth would guide you to Christ and push
you towards Christ right if I was able
to have the Holy Spirit why did I still
choose Islam over Christianity I would
say that you didn't have the Holy Spirit
so what what is that what I had what is
that I would say that you was probably
around the environment where people
looked like they they protrayed a
certain image that this is what Having
the Holy Spirit looks like right you
said you part of the Pentecostal right
so this is what it looks like biblically
you got to look at what it looks like
biblically though biblically it doesn't
match up you know what I'm saying so
just because let's say maybe they was
speaking in so-called
tongues that's not the that's not what
it was in the Bible so that's my thing
why is there so many different
variations of what each uh denomination
thinks means that God has chosen them
good question because man twists things
but hold on why are they able to twist
but hold on no they do the same with
Islam you have sunnis and you have Shia
within sunnis you have
havei Asar all these kind of people
right all these divided sects that even
fight each other oned you know what I'm
saying so you have these differences in
Islam too that doesn't now I wouldn't
say that just because they're different
that this makes Islam false they still
follow the same Quran at the end of the
day but but they don't though because if
you go to Morocco they use the war Quran
if you go to Egypt they use the H Quran
they're different mostly the same but a
lot of differences in them differences
that really matter for example one
difference and we have the same thing
going on in Christianity and different
there's thousands of denominations so so
this is what I'm asking what what what
makes Christianity
false why is there so many why do you
believe in Christianity okay so are you
saying I I'll tell you in a second cuz
that's a good question are you saying
that denominations different
denominations shows that a religion is
false why do we have Mormonism why do
you have that's not Christianity
Catholicism but no I'm talking about
Mormonism what do you think about
Catholicism they're Brothers but what
I'm saying is is does different
denominations make a religion
false I just think that such a uh a big
variation in what you're supposed to be
following
is is concerning okay so then do you
have the same concerns in Islam when you
have a literal divide with sunnis and
Shi but it's not as big as it come on
Thousand it's thousands thousands
denominations no it's that's s Isam
matter of fact Muhammad says that the
the religion is going to be split into
over 70 sex you know and only one of
them is going to be true isn't that
concerning yeah so I I appreciate your
honesty this is what I'm saying you got
to be consistent if Christianity is
concerning because there's different
denominations you have to look at the
Islam with the same lens and say Islam
is equally concerning because there's a
bunch of different denominations you
have to be consider and honest with that
but here's what my position I wouldn't
say that that makes Islam false I
wouldn't say that what I would do is I
will look at what the Quran says and I
will look at the character of Muhammad
and see if he truly came from God is the
Quran really the word of God that's what
I would see can we go to my question
please oh yeah what's your question so
so what made you go into Christianity
and like all right so question I want to
know your story yeah so the reason the
question is why do I believe in
Christianity the reason why
but but aside others right the reason
why I believe in Christianity is because
one I see a consistent message between
from Moses all the way to Jesus we see
God's consistent theme that one man has
a problem it's sin two the answer to sin
is God himself he's going to come and
answer it for us how it's through the
Messiah so all the way from the Torah it
foretells the Messiah coming and
redeeming us from our sin from from
Moses to David and the Psalms Zechariah
to Daniel to Malachi then all the way to
Jesus so Jesus says all these
Pro look look don't worry about the
crowd but Jesus says all these prophets
they spoke of me and when I look at that
I see whoo Isaiah said that g the
Messiah is going to suffer for my sins
700 years before he did it it says he'll
be pierced for my sins uh bruised for my
transgressions and he's going to Bear my
iniquities this is 700 years before
Jesus was born I I wanted to ask like
genuine question um so you know how
people say like Jesus died for our sins
Jesus di for our sins yeah so does that
does that like some people say on the
one where like they can get away with
doing sins now like no no Absol
absolutely not I just I just want to
know the like so yeah here's the answer
to that so that would be false matter of
fact Jesus says this that not everyone
who calls me Lord on that day will get
into the kingdom of heaven but those who
do the will of my father right so this
is Matthew chapter 7 okay so Matthew
chapter 7 he says that those who are
doing wickedness but who are calling me
Lord they're Hypocrites and he's going
to throw them in Hellfire okay so that's
number one secondly this is what he says
in Romans chapter 6 it says should we
continue in sin so that God's grace May
abound he says by no means absolutely
not how can we who died to sin still
live in it so as a Christian you're dead
to sin you put away your old self and
because Christ gave his life for you you
lived in gratitude and say thank you my
life is now yours so you give up that
sin okay so you can't go around sinning
cuz Jesus died for you absolutely not
makees sense okay that that that makes
sense to me absolutely so look guys you
could look into if you have another
question you can ask but look into this
like like I've looked into that all my
life and you you didn't know Messiah was
the son of
God that wasn't the definition that I
she not look I she a some schol or
something
basic information of a basic individual
you when she saying that I if I was a
random person here like some mad
questions and that they're not they're
not going to know everything of course
but I want everyone to know that we are
not perfect Muslims we are not
Scholars so yeah you guys had you guys
had a you guys had a great conversation
man so I than you guys absolutely
absolutely my God logic
[Music]